welcome today's talk is the human nature
of failure and resiliency by vm please
give her a warm welcome
[Applause]
Hey
hi oh my gosh the microphone is on umm
hey everyone I have a lot to cover so
we're just going to dive right in
Who am I why am I here my name is VM
brewer but because we're all friends
here you can call me Vicky plus the
virtual machine jokes have gotten old
please don't think yours is original
because it's not I'm the author of this
which is as far as we can tell the very
first book on how to contribute to free
and open-source software I am an
authoring community moderator for
open-source comm the vice-president of
the open source initiative I'm an open
source policy and strategy freelancer
and I do training on how to do this sort
of stuff right here but before I did all
of this I used to lead software
engineering departments and while I was
doing that I started studying failure as
a bit of a hobby I did a lot of research
into failure this is a link to a
bibliography of all that research
currently there are 205 items in this
bibliography it adds up to approximately
3,500 pages worth of reacher research
into failure
now this talk is going to take all of
that and give you the greatest hits the
things that are common across all those
3,500 pages of research into failure I'm
gonna give it to you today in
approximately 40 minutes here they are
here's a quick summary these are the
themes that are common across all of
that research and what I'm going to
share with you today like I said there
are thousands of pages here I'm not
going to get into everything um I'm also
not going to give you the secret serum
that will prevent failure for you from
here on out I'm just not going to do it
because it's not possible I will however
give you a list of questions of things
you should consider when you want to
start succeeding with failure I am only
going to give you an overview again
because dude
3500 pages what the hell
so um there will hopefully be time for
questions if not now there is a break
afterwards so catch me afterward and we
can talk about failure it's absolutely
fascinating so another thing I need to
mention has a limitation of this talk it
does go into a lot of psychology and
what I have found is most of the
research almost all of the research is
done in a Western mindset using Western
psychology on Western individuals and
unrelated recent studies have shown that
a lot of these psychological concepts
that we in Western cultures believe are
solid truths don't actually hold true as
well for Europe for Eastern Asian
African cultures so just be aware there
is a bias here for Western minds and
finally do save questions for the end
which is something I really don't have
to say at PyCon but I include this slide
anyway so let's get into those common
themes and we're going to start with
complexity the world is complex this
shouldn't come as a surprise to anyone
people are complex he'll be complexity
hiding in something as simple as
chocolate chip cookies is really quite
mind-blowing we as humans however we
don't like complexity and that leads us
to some very unfortunate tendencies for
starters we have a tendency to ignore
complexity completely lalalalala nothing
to see here moving on everything around
us is constantly changing constantly
evolving yet research shows we prefer to
operate as though we are in a static
environment we will start a project
we'll take a snapshot in our brain of
how things are right then and then we'll
operate within the snapshot while the
rest of the world moves on without us as
you can imagine this can lead to some
problems research also shows that we
dislike variation we like things to be
just so and we like them to stay that
way hence that snapshot we also prefer
to operate in serial rather than
parallel because that minimizes
complexity and it allows us to focus our
efforts on what we then consider to be
the best
option so we focus on these static now
rather than the ever-changing complexity
of the future and the parallel projects
so we can't know everything and we'd
like to think we do but we really can't
and because we're more comfortable with
what we know we avoid everything we
don't and this this is a problem we
don't actually know as much as we think
we know we are each and every one of us
a walking talking dunning-kruger Film
Festival so we don't know we think we
know more than we do
and because of that we have a tendency
to overlook a lot of things and these
are the unknown unknowns and rather than
just some silly thing a politician said
once this is actually a real
psychological concept it's a latent
error
Leyton errors are overlooked near-misses
layton errors look an awful lot like
successes because they haven't failed
yet and that's because latent errors
have yet to meet their enabling
condition an enabling condition is that
trigger that turns a latent error to the
dark side of failure so there is a very
good example I like to use for latent
errors meeting they're enabling
conditions now I won't be able to see
when you raise your hand but I'm going
to ask you to raise your hands anyway
how many of you out there remember the
Deepwater Horizon tragedy that happened
a few years ago yeah oil rig in the Gulf
of Mexico went boom bad thing so what
happened there was you had to latent
errors really there was a lot going on
but we're going to minimize things
because again not going into detail we
had to latent errors you had somebody
performing a cementing procedure and
that cementing procedure was filling a
pipe with cement and while he was doing
so he was doing it wrong normally that's
fine that's perfectly fine he was doing
it the way that they always do it and
there was never a problem but he was
doing it wrong and because of that gas
was escaping from the pipe that's latent
error number one incorrect cementing
procedure latent error number two
somebody was welding nearby usually not
a problem you can have these things in
close proximity all the time and it's in
the oil rig right someone's always
cementing and someone is always welding
not a problem
okay so two Layton errors and then we
have our enabling condition something
that does not happen very often
especially not on the high seas and that
is it was a windless day so thanks to
that windless day that welding that
spark caught the gas there was an
explosion it killed 11 people 16 others
were critically injured very very bad
and we had the worst environmental
disaster our country has ever seen
because of latent errors meeting their
enabling condition now it is possible to
spot latent errors um you can look for
them in your post mortems do you do post
mortems you probably should as you're
doing that as you're looking at your
post mortem and you're looking at how
things went ask the group so what went
right we've been looking at what went
wrong but what went right pretty much by
chance those are probably your latent
errors and things you should consider
for your next project but here's the
problem we're really bad at post mortems
we just don't know how to do them um so
we focus on symptoms rather than causes
when we do look for causes we look for
just one we look for root cause I'm
sorry folks gonna tear down your little
house of cards here there is never just
one root root cause we also have
selection bias we prefer to look at the
easy things the things we can actually
answer very quickly because it makes us
feel accomplished another form of
selection bias that we have is that we
only post-mortem the things that went
wrong rather than the things that went
right as well if you post-mortem the
things that went right you're more
likely to spot those latent errors that
never met they're enabling conditions
but we don't do that for us post mortems
are things that you only do when [ __ ]
goes wrong so what do we do
how can we minimize these tendencies we
have with just avoiding complexity
well for starters Dupree mortems before
you even start your project do a
pre-mortem rather than a post-mortem and
start looking for things that might go
wrong start looking for latent errors
come up with contingency plans for all
of them
get skeptics in the room who will
question all of your assumptions we'll
talk a lot more about that in a moment
and then make your plan in your
pre-mortem
but then plan to change the plan because
if you remember you take that snapshot
right and we like to work inside the
snapshot once in a while plan to pause
bring your snapshot into modern times
and take it again and once you take that
new snapshot you might have to adjust
your project accordingly now let's dive
into assumptions man nearly every single
piece of research in that bibliography
has terrible things to say about
assumptions this is when those lessons
we never seem to learn for some reason
we always assume when we always assume
we're assuming and they were okay with
assuming we assume research has nothing
nice to say about assumptions all for
starters assumptions are usually based
on incorrect and invalid information we
often base them on those snapshots we
take in our brain and those snapshots
again they're static where as the world
has moved on so our snapshots are wrong
our assumptions are wrong we then use
those assumptions as a basis for a set
of heuristics
which we apply to real world situations
right now and that's not going to work
how many of you have tried to estimate
how long it's going to take to complete
a project how many of you are actually
right probably none of you if I could
see your hands and you were you had them
still up you would be liars every one of
you other really popular assumptions
that we make in technology that we
probably should stop doing user needs
what is our user actually trying to
accomplish we think we know but we
really don't
and yet we assume we move on and we
develop things
what business are we really in this is
something startups never seem to answer
and they keep failing because of it they
don't know why they're in business
assumptions usually are based upon a
poor problem definition we are so bad at
this I am a freelancer now I work with
companies to help them with their
open-source strategy and compliance and
all that sort of stuff and they come to
me and they say Viki we want to do open
source and I say great I want to help
you do open source why do you want to do
it what do you want to get out of it
what problem are you looking to solve
for your business and almost entirely
except for one client I'm working with
right now who is so amazing they don't
have an answer they don't know why they
want to do this and this is common we
never really know why we're doing stuff
we have a problem we're looking to solve
but we haven't defined that problem and
so we're basing our assumption on the
problem that is not defined and so if we
haven't defined our problem and we're
basing our assumptions on an undefined
problem we're basing our solutions on an
undefined problem and we're naturally
going to fail because we're doing the
wrong thing it is absolutely impossible
in technology to fail fast if you don't
define success you must know what you're
trying to accomplish because if you
don't define success you can't define
failure you can't fail fast if you don't
know what failure even is now we in tech
like to say that we don't have time for
that holy crap no we are totally agile
we are just iterative and it's great you
know we're gonna just build [ __ ] and
move fast and break stuff and it's
amazing but the thing is we don't really
have the time to do that but we don't
have time to check the assumptions we
have the time to do that and to build
the wrong thing for the wrong person
then scrap it because we don't check our
assumptions it's terrible so you do have
to question your assumptions as you are
doing this entire process always
question them and that's because
psychologists have found over and over
again that unquestioned assumptions
become facts in the minds of the hearers
we have all seen this in play when
you're sitting there in a meeting and
the person at the top of the desk
top of the table there says so how long
is it going to take to do this someone
else at the table raises their hand they
say we assume this will take two weeks
but we need to confirm research shows
that for almost everyone in that room
especially the person at the head of the
table they don't hear anything after two
weeks it's it's just a psychological
thing we don't hear and it needs to we
need to confirm so this is really common
in all cultures across all industries
but we in technology seem to get bitten
by it a lot so assumptions they're
horrible they're terrible they are in
fact the root of all evil they're not
the next one is actually the root of all
evil what do we do to minimize the
impact well please define your problem
please not only define your problem but
communicates the definition of the
problem because otherwise you will be
sitting in that room with all those
people and you'll ask them what are we
trying to accomplish if each and every
person in that room does not have the
exact same answer then you still have
assumptions that you need to fix and
communication that you need to fix as
well
Duprey mortems lists and verify not only
those latent errors don't just look for
those but explicitly call out every
single assumption that you are making be
very obvious about it it's great to have
assumptions they're shortcuts they allow
us to move more quickly but be aware of
your assumptions and once you have those
write them down and you need to do this
because you later need to go back and
revisit them throughout the process just
check in every once in a while and those
assumptions because again you're working
in your snapshot you need to update your
snapshot to the now and when you're
updating your snapshot to the now also
go through all of your assumptions
because some of them might no longer be
assumptions now you might have knowledge
rather than an assumption but you're not
gonna know that if you don't verify and
this actually is the root of all evil
businesses clubs projects any group of
human
beings every piece of research shows
that human beings are the primary cause
of failure surprising huh
but we can't exactly get rid of them I
highly recommend you do not get rid of
human beings so that is not the solution
here we are kind of a problematic
species we are fairly arrogant as the
top of the food chain we like to think
Ellen Langer is a psychologist at
Harvard she was the first person to to
publish a paper on this
it's called illusion of control we as
humans again arrogant we like to think
we have a lot of control over things and
we don't we overestimate the impact our
actions can have and we overestimate
even what we can just influence let
alone control and because of that we
ignore latent errors because we think we
are in control again near misses
remember deepwater horizon now if we
look for latent errors if we're not
actively ignoring them we can do
something about latent errors we can
stop that man from doing his cementing
procedure incorrectly we can stop that
man
from doing the welding we can control
these two things because we can see them
and go that's not gonna go well and we
can control that but what we can never
do is we can never make the wind blow we
can never control enabling conditions
and therefore we can never control fully
any situation wherein we can think we
can but we're wrong we just can't do it
so how is your team organized your team
your project your company how is it
actually physically structured and
organized you know what's your hierarchy
and all that goodness because that
organization can have a really dramatic
effect on the its success rate and on
its reaction to failures are you in
silos are you in organizational silos
who here knows what I mean by
organizational silo hey not quite
everyone the other people are probably
just doing Twitter but
so organizational silos you've got this
team here team C B and a and they're all
working on their own little things very
happily going along but they're not
communicating nobody really knows what
anyone else is doing and this is a
problem it dilutes responsibility for
failure let's say something goes wrong
over here in team a there's a failure in
team a and it could possibly affect
teams B and C but there's no
communication they don't tell them that
so teams B and C are gonna fail as well
because nobody has shared information
with them silos hamper communication
they obscure information and they're a
problem and they increase failures
within an organization another problem
is when your team is organized around
processes and let's say you've got one
team that's dedicated 100% to testing
and this team is writing that team is
designing and this team is you know
deploying their all-around processes now
what happens if the process is what's
causing the failure what do you do that
well studies show that we as human
beings are less likely to change the
process because it also might mean we
have to change the organizational
structure in some way and so we don't do
it and we continue using broken
processes because of it and that leads
to a lot more failures now both with
silos and with with these process
organized things it does require a reorg
Anora to fix unfortunately and those are
we probably all know reorg than ever fun
but it will help reduce failures if you
have multidisciplinary teams because you
get a lot more communication across
teams if you have people who cross
procedural boundaries within a team and
you get a lot more people who are asking
questions and questioning assumptions
so regardless of the structure of your
team your group your project whatever it
is regardless of their structure how
does it react when something fails does
it punish people for failures this is
pretty common for people to be punished
for failures if that happens it's
actually a bigger problem than the
failure itself because it increases the
the impact of the failure that's because
if people are afraid of being punished
for failure they stop reporting failures
and if people stop reporting failures it
is impossible for you to learn from
failures because that is the only way to
prevent failures is to have failures and
learn from them unshared failures are
just the experience of an individual and
that's it and I can stand right here on
this kind of squeaky podium thing I can
stand right here and I can gain
experience it just happens to me now if
I want to learn from that experience it
takes an extra step that's an activity
that's something I have to manually do
the experience comes at me for free
whether I like it or not it's my choice
whether I learn from it and for failure
it's the same thing we can't learn from
failures if we don't share them you
don't have the information to share
bigger problem or another problem with
people being afraid of punishment for
failure is that they stop innovating
they stop trying new things and I'm not
just talking like that Silicon Valley
disrupting sort of innovation I'm not
talking about that talking about the
kind of innovation that actually matters
the innovation of streamlining a
workflow the innovation of trying a new
library just small everyday innovations
that add up to a great deal of
improvement in your life we stop doing
it because we're afraid we're going to
get punished should it fail so that's a
big problem I've had people say don't
worry we don't have that problem I never
hear about failures at all
really did you just hear what I said
people oh yeah if you're not hearing
about it doesn't mean it's not happening
just means they're hidden and that's
worse than not having failures at all
another common problem with humans and
also I might I add my favorite cognitive
bias I do as a matter of fact have a
favorite cognitive bias normalization of
deviance Diane Vaughan is an American
sociologist she studied the space
shuttle Challenger explosion and she is
the first person to write about the
normalization of deviance yeah Diane so
normalized a getting difficult to speak
up here normalization of deviance is
when you have a latent error lying right
there in the open and rather than
picking it up and putting it away you
just step over it you just avoid it you
know you just completely ignore lalala
there is no latent error there all right
this is a big problem an example I like
to give of normalized deviance is when
let's say you were a new programmer at a
company your talen log files as one is
want to do and you're looking at log
files and this error keeps popping up
and you're like holy [ __ ] what is this
error OMG and you run to the senior
developer and you're like hey what's
this error and they say don't worry
happens all the time we just ignore it
um hey as somebody who used to run
software engineering departments I'm
gonna tell you to get that [ __ ] out of
the log because it's noise that's
blocking my signal so okay that's
problem number one but if it's an actual
legitimate problem if that error in your
log is legit then I'm sorry you are one
race condition away from catastrophe
that's a latent error that you are
ignoring you have normalized that
deviance
so normalization of deviance we do it
all the time we are very familiar with
pressure and stress in technology we
have this unfortunate tendency across
all of humanity but particularly in
technology also medical we do a lot of
this
we push ourselves too hard we try doing
too much in too little time usually for
no good purpose at all and this leads to
a lot of problem the obvious problems
are fatigue driven errors read the
studies in the bibliography about the
impact of this on your healthcare and
you will this is real this is a big
problem but it also is a problem because
when we're fatigued when we're tired
when we're stressed out we have a
tendency research shows to rely more on
untested assumptions we will make
wild-ass guesses and run with them and
that's perfectly fine we think is cool
it's ok I'm totally stressed I've got
[ __ ] to do I've just got to move on but
it's a problem and it leads to a lot
more failures so remember when I
mentioned that we like to focus on just
that one thing we're working in serial
rather than parallel right we also have
a really hard time not seeing that one
thing through to the end which is a big
problem if we haven't bothered to define
what the end is frankly so we're just
going to keep on going we're never going
to stop because we don't know what done
looks like and that's a big problem
obviously but then we will have the sunk
cost fallacy where people are like we've
taken so much time and put in so much
effort we should just see it through
right ok maybe but usually that's not
the case
we also have a problem with killing
things before they fail when we've got
project champions those people who are
in the group and they've got this
reality distortion field you know and
they're just waving the flag we can do
it we can do it and they just get this
groupthink of everyone involved in the
project who they get this deeply deeply
held belief that yeah we can do it yeah
we can succeed even when all evidence is
to the contrary people have blind faith
that yes we can do this when there's no
proof that they actually can and so what
you end up with is the shambling zombies
project that never dies another reason
we can't pull the
is we aren't taught how to communicate
we think we're being very nice by
allowing something to continue rather
than telling people I'm sorry we have to
pull the plug on your project there are
really good easy empathetic ways to tell
people that we're pulling the plug on
your project you're not being a jerk by
doing that you can say it in a jerky way
and then yeah you are a jerk but we
don't teach people how to do this
properly and so projects go on and on
and on and finally they fail and
everyone's upset so what do we do about
this
what do we do about I already mentioned
we can't get rid of humans that's not
one of the options organizational
changes dealing with people anything
dealing with people is hard I'm in
management trust me it's hard they're
hard to start they're even harder to
finish so keep in mind this is these are
going to be very difficult things but
they're usually worthwhile for starters
research shows again and again and again
any sort of organizational initiative if
it doesn't get support from the top this
is where grass roots does not
necessarily work you have to get support
from the top or else your organizational
change will not succeed ideally your
support from the top and this failure
stopping initiative should be the
leaders discussing their own failures
their leaders showing what they've
learned from their failures and showing
people it's okay and that starts to
create something that we call an
environment a psychological safety
because people see it's okay to fail now
again experiences automatic learning is
not mistakes are also not automatic
mistakes are only mistakes because
somebody points out and says yo that's a
mistake before that it's just a learning
opportunity it's just experience now
learning it develops intuition it
develops skills how many of you out
there are senior technical staff okay I
can actually see these hand a little bit
so I lied earlier um you can put your
hands down now I can guarantee you
didn't become senior tuck
Nicolle staff because of your age you
became senior technical staff because
dude you've seen some [ __ ] man okay and
I mean you've experienced failure but
you learned from it you develop
intuition and skill and you're using
those past failures to prevent future
failures so that's really important we
need the failures to do this but you
can't do that if you're not Nate an
environment where it's safe to make the
failure study's finally are coming out
all about psychological safety and you
can find them in the bibliography and we
are showing that psychologically safe
teams are the ones that the most
productive they are the most innovative
they are the most cost effective so
aside from taking care of your team
being just the right thing to do in a
humane way if that's not good enough for
you oh honey please it is so good for
your bottom line so there's lots of good
reasons to create psychologically safe
teams so as you're doing your pre
mortems your post mortems as you're
having all these discussions around your
project bring in outside people and not
just outside from other teams other
development teams but I'm talking you
know bring in customer service bring in
users bring in marketing and finance
bring in people who don't think the same
way you do and have them in your
pre-mortem have them in your post mortem
they're going to ask a lot of really
interesting questions about things that
you have been ignoring and glossing over
these are project skeptics these are
these are truth seekers and they are
really valuable
they help surface a lot of things that
you otherwise wouldn't see and our
latent errors or failures waiting to
happen
you can also make your projects just
more survivable you know just if you're
going to try stuff make it easier to try
stuff first of all the easiest project
to survive is one you don't even start
so ask yourself do we really need to do
this do we really need to reinvent the
wheel again or can't we just use it
library that someone else has used right
so don't start them at all as manager I
like this one build in checkpoints and
milestones into every project and if you
do funding for a project if you're in a
big corporation that does that sort of
funding thing then only fund to a
checkpoint otherwise just make this
checkpoint a place where everyone in the
entire organization knows this is a no
go no-go situation if you're not
actually moving us towards our goal at
that checkpoint we will probably cancel
you but that's okay and make sure
everyone knows that's okay it's not a
sign that you have failed in any way
just means we're going to move on to
something else it's fine
and if you do have something that is
potentially not very survivable if you
have a project that is going to be a
little more complicated or involved spin
it off get it away if you have a project
that's going to explode honey get it
away from the things that might be hit
by the shrapnel you know because
otherwise that you're going to have
ripple effects from that potential
failure should it actually fail all
right so let's talk about some ways that
you can work with failure experiments
are controlled failure and they are
amazing we literally as human beings
would not be here without failure and
that's because of evolution in
life-forms as in all other things no
change is possible without some failure
evolution itself is just a constant
series of works for now solutions and
maybe in a thousand years will have a
better it works for now solution it's
just constant series of these so your
experimentation should also be similarly
continuous if you want your business in
your project to evolve as you're doing
your experiments you have something in
mind we're testing for this we want it
to look like this and this is your
success right redefine that success
don't have your success for your
experiment B we got the outcome that we
were hoping for have success for your
experiment mean o we learn something
really good that we can use for future
experiments so seek the truth first and
traditional success second now
experiments can be very risky remember
the shrapnel all right but that doesn't
mean they all have to be risky think of
experiments like your financial
portfolio balance them with high risk
and low risk because otherwise you're
going to put your company your team your
project all these things at jeopardy if
everything is high risk also like
investing do it for the long-term right
you don't just do that day trading and
assume you're going to make millions of
dollars because that's not the way
trading works if you invest in the long
term with your experiments you are
experimenting multiple times you're not
just trying once having it not get the
outcome you want and then walking away
done we tried it it's not going to work
because that's that's not the way you
can have successful experiments the
nature of successful experiments we we
do like to say fail fast most of us
don't really know what that entails but
it does start with making things small
and survivable again I talked about
survivable with that nice little
shrapnel metaphor but if we keep
experiments small not only are they
quicker to iterate upon but it also
means that the outcomes are very very
closely situated to the actions which
means we can more easily determine cause
and effect when you go into an
experiment assume they're going to fail
I just said assume I'm sorry we're not
supposed to assume anything I will
acknowledge that we are assuming here
and I will confirm it later but expect
that some of them will fail because if
you don't then you're going to be very
disappointed with your experiments and
you have explicit success and failure
criteria know what you're looking for
and if you don't know that you can't
know when you're not hitting that mark
you can't know what failure looks like
and to make everybody again more
psychologically safe have an exit
strategy one of the things that research
finds is that people are unwilling to
say that their experiment failed because
they don't know what's going to happen
to them personally at the end well my
project failed so what am I gonna get
canned you you can come up with an exit
strategy for these things you can make
people feel more secure they know what's
going to happen to them at the end and
it's not bad but if you don't have an
exit strategy people will be
uncomfortable
okay so introspection which is really
not a great title for this slide but
we're gonna work with it you each and
every one of you beautiful individuals
in this this hall you want to get better
from failure you want to learn from it
the best way to do that is to actively
start inspecting your failure
environment so what sort of questions
should you be asking what are you trying
to accomplish if you can't answer that
and if everyone in your team in your
project can't answer that the same way
you might have a problem step number one
make sure you know what you're doing
what's your user trying to accomplish if
you're doing this for yourself whatever
your project is that's one thing but if
you're doing it for some external entity
or person make sure you don't assume you
know the answer to this question what
are those assumptions list them out be
very explicit about it because you want
to check in on them to make sure they
still hold true or not true or you still
need more information have you looked
for latent errors probably not because
most people don't
what does failure look like most people
if you think of this at all you think of
it in the success case but it's not
always obvious it's not simply black and
white that failure is the opposite of
what you had to find a success so be
very explicit what failure looks like
and then be very clear with people
what's going to happen should their
experiment fail because then they will
feel more safe even trying because there
isn't that giant question mark hanging
over their heads
you have a post mortem process do you
have a pre Motum process figure that out
in advance so everybody knows there is
an preset expectation that you will be
doing this how does your organization
treat failure if it punishes failure you
can try to change your organization but
frankly between you me and the wall get
out because there are some things that
you just can't change on your own and if
your organization is pointing fingers
and blaming people and punishing for
failure that's one of the things that's
going to be very difficult for you to
change as is an a culture that doesn't
provide psychological safety if you're
not in a psychologically safe
environment if you don't feel you have
the freedom and the support to
experiment and to fail then you might
need to find a job that will allow you
to do that now the answers to all of
these questions they're going to be
different for each and every project
each and every team each and every
company right and so therefore the
solutions are also going to be different
for each and every project and team and
company and that's why there is no
silver bullet here that's why I can't
just hand you this happy little serum
that's going to make all failure go away
forever it's actually really hard to do
this properly you do have to think
everything through
so please just take the time ask these
questions answer these questions and
communicate your failures across the
entire organization for those of us
those of you who have been snapping
pictures all this of all the slides
you're going to be very disappointed to
learn they're already available online
so they are here at internet archive
also here is a link to that bibliography
I mentioned my contact information
twitter handle at the top freenode IRC
Ian Nick in the middle and my email
address and of course my book I will
leave this up while we do Q&A so are
there any questions but not comments
disguised as questions please come on up
to the microphone it looks like we have
three and a half minutes maybe four
minutes
thank you for the talk thank you welcome
I'm live demo a lot of these complexity
analyses are always concerning about
what happens when things go wrong with
complexity and I feel like the other
half of the coin is King complexity work
for us like are there anything like
latent successes and I think a lot of
people would call this luck but I'm
curious have anything in the research
has talked about latent successes or how
interacting variables might contribute
to our success they they do talk a lot
about variables um very few of them
think of them or discuss them in context
of latent successes because nobody's
interested in that frankly we're all
very interested in the failures because
we love watching a train wreck
it's just when those things we do in
humanity right we we love clicking
through on those horrible clickbait you
know things that we see on BuzzFeed so
no that's it's actually a really good
perspective though which is why I
recommend that in your post-mortem you
also look at the successes right because
those are very telling as well they can
tell you a lot about a what you did
wrong but also they can help find the
latent errors next hi
for those of us who are not at the top
or close to the top what tips if any of
you have for trying to convince upwards
to adopt things like this or how do we
be more helpful towards leaders who do
want to adopt things ideas like this you
see this is really weird because I'm
used to repeating the questions and I
don't have to so so how do you manage up
essentially yeah it depends I don't know
the people you're working with and the
answer to how do I manage up or how do I
manage at all is one of ethical
manipulation and in order to ethically
manipulate you have to know which
buttons to push and those buttons are
different for everyone but it you do
have to understand what they value right
do they value certain things like you
know success probably you know and and
so you can couch things in a term in
terms of things that will push their
buttons that will help them understand
this isn't just for us this is also
going to help you
and help show them how this is going to
support everyone in the group but it can
often helped you lead by example here
and rather than going up first go
lateral and work within your team and
have your team be this shining example
of collaboration and communication and
you know pre-mortem x' and post-mortems
and documentation oh for love a dog
please doc everything you know and that
can help then become your pilot project
and you can point to it it's very
helpful to point to something and say
look this is successful can you help me
scale this up and they're more likely to
listen to you at that point thank you
welcome hello hi thanks
so you mentioned spin it off for a
high-risk project that kind of felt like
just basically delegating off like
people who are gonna die in an explosion
to die what can you say a little more
about that
so this often is done with companies as
they are they they want to do some sort
of skunkworks type thing and it's not
going to work in their existing
organization because it's going to make
other people jealous that they're not
working on the skunkworks
it might actually impact their work on
other products you know and so they will
spin it off into another company do
another team into a lab and they will
spin it off like that now well I do say
explosion and shrapnel that does imply
that I assume which we shouldn't do I
assume it's going to fail and it might
not so I'm not necessarily sending
people off to their deaths because it
could be a very successful situation and
often spinning these projects out in
that way gives people a lot more freedom
than they would otherwise so they can
experiment more and do things that they
wouldn't otherwise be able to do in the
typical structure of the group they were
in so there it does give you a lot more
freedom in that way and again have an
exit strategy let people know what
happens if this fails what happens if we
can't make this experiment work right
we're gonna bring you all back in you're
gonna work
and this we're gonna move you to another
lab so people know that they're not just
going to get cut okay thank you welcome
we are have 40 minutes or 40 seconds if
there's any more questions otherwise
okay great thank you all thank you